president putin laying a wreath at the
tomb of the unknown soldier like a host
of visiting western dignitaries have
over the past few weeks when diplomacy
seemed more alive than it does now
foreign
at a less formal event just outside
moscow a group of military reenactors
perform for the crowds
it's defender of the fatherland day in
russia a national holiday and there are
events across the country to commemorate
world war ii
it's unlikely the timing of this is a
coincidence vladimir putin is a master
at using history for his own ends or his
particular version of it and this is the
perfect moment to whip up patriotic
further for whatever he wants to do next
in ukraine
no one we speak to thinks russia is at
fault for the latest spike intentions
but it does hit close to home this man
lost a relative in the separatist
republics he says he went out one day
when the ukrainian army was in town and
never came home
yesterday
[Music]
one of the separatist leaders said he'd
call for help from big russia when he
needed it
but the russian troops weren't there yet
back in moscow the freshly sanctioned
now include russia's powerful defense
minister sergey shoigu
and 351 russian mps who voted yes to
independents
[Music]
but for all the day's festivities russia
is increasingly isolated and
increasingly defensive
it's hard to see a way back
down in magnay sky news
near moscow